today on the Matt Walsh show Media
Matters attacks The Daily wire because
we committed the sin of calling males
male so we'll we'll go through that
today they're very upset about it
and as they are every single time we say
anything about anything so we'll talk
about that also five headlines including
the media is increasingly desperate
attempt but also hilarious increasingly
desperate increasingly hilarious
attempts to make stacey abrams into some
sort of superstar and it's it's it's
really gotten pretty absurd so we'll
talk about that and in our daily
cancellation i canceled the NFL for
considering what i think maybe one of
the most insane affirmative action
schemes ever devised
certainly in professional sports also
will have why i'm wrong email and much
more all the way but first i want to
tell you about life lock you know i've
been almost duped a time or two myself
because these these internet scammers I
like to think I'm you know I'm pretty
I'm pretty jaded I'm pretty ready for
people to try to scam me especially when
it comes to emails but they're getting
pretty clever and that's why there are a
lot of close calls and that's why you
want to be sure that you're protected
the corner virus pandemic has sparked a
massive increase in the number of
cybercrime complaints flowing into the
FBI the agency's internet Crime
Complaint Center which typically
receives a thousand complaints per day
before the pandemic is now receiving
three to four thousand per day corta
virus related schemes include domain
names spoofing personal protective
equipment vendors scams promising
government checks fraudulent kovin
charities all kinds of stuff like that
the ones with the charities are the
worst because they're taking advantage
of your of your charitable nature every
day we put our information at risk on
the internet no matter how careful you
are and cyber criminals keep finding new
ways to steal your identities the good
thing though is that there is life lock
life lock is a leader in identity theft
protection life lock detects a wide
range of identity thefts like your
social security number for sale in the
dark web all kinds of things that you
may not be able to detect yourself look
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but life lock and see threats
that you might miss on your own if
you're just monitoring your credit
so join now and save up to 25% on your
first year go to LifeLock comm slash
walsh that's a LifeLock comm slash walsh
LifeLock comm slash walls for 25% off
okay by the way I don't mean to brag I
don't know if you can tell but I did get
my hair cut over the weekend so for the
first time in two months I was able to
get my hair cut you know I feel like
that's the great privilege now in
American life is if you're in a a
haircut State or not maybe that's what
the coming Civil War will be over it's
you know haircut vert state's first non
haircut States
the thing is oh I could tell how
desperate people are because my the
place where I get my hair cut opened
reopened for the first time on Sunday at
10:00 a.m. by 10:15 a.m. on Sunday there
was a three and a half hour wait so and
I kept thinking just how bad I feel for
the people working at these haircut
places you know because they just have
to deal with these long lines just one
shaggy-dog after another coming in and
they're wearing masks the whole time and
there's hair flying a live look they're
probably getting hair in the mask that
can't be sanitary so but then again
they're back at work so I'm sure that's
that's a good thing as well okay we're
gonna start with our good friends over
at Media Matters who are of course huge
fans of this show and of The Daily wire
in general they published another
lengthy expose about us on Friday now
this is to be distinguished from the
regular almost daily oh really I think
literally daily little posts they do
about whatever offensive thing that one
of us might have happened to say that
day so those sorts of things that you
expect but then every once a while they
go more in depth in trying to really
reveal our bigotry and show what what
nasty horrible people we are so they
tried that again on Friday with this
article that the headline daily wire
host demean trans high school athletes
at center of alliance defending case now
the author Alex Patterson introduces the
article this well this way on Twitter it
says the daily wires anti
trans pundits matt walsh ben shapiro and
michael knowles repeatedly misgendered
and demeaned to teenage a athletes
grown-ass men commenting about teenagers
genitals disgusting
yes disgusting disgusting it's so
disgusting that we would dare mention
that males are males
what would a horrible and disgusting an
inappropriate thing absolutely
inappropriate shocking scandalizing
because because that's what alex means
here right we commented on teenagers
genitals in the sense that we said males
are males so in that way you know the
doctor when the doctor tells you it's a
boy he's commenting on the baby's
genitals quite literally he is looking
at the genitals and announcing the sex
so when the doctor tells you that would
you rip you pervert what are you doing
commenting on my baby's genitals well
Alex by the way what does that tell you
you know the people in the medical
profession when they want to determine
the sex of a baby they look at the
generals what does that tell you think
about that for a second use your brain
not to comment on your internal organs
especially one that I'm not sure you
actually possess okay let's check out
the article this is this is a pretty fun
we'll take a look at it and actually if
you could producer please play a little
bit of sad violin music while I read
this because it will help set the tone I
think and get us all in the mood of this
article okay it says across several
pieces of online content and podcasts
The Daily wires ben shapiro matt walsh
and michael knowles attacked and
misgendered two trans teenagers at the
center of a lawsuit from extreme anti
LGBTQ group Alliance defending freedom
that seeks to prevent them from
competing in girls sports since May 11th
the reliably anti-trans outlet and
pundits have posted four podcast
segments that received over two hundred
and fifteen thousand views on YouTube
and two articles that are two combined
158,000 interactions on Facebook the
pundits repeatedly misgendered the teen
athletes and fear monger about
trans-inclusive sports with Knowles
claiming that recognizing transgender
people is part of an agenda to end
objective reality shameful what a bigot
Knowles is after National Review first
reported on the story on May 11th daily
wire published two articles one written
by Walsh and the other by Amanda presto
Giacomo that repeatedly misgendered the
athletes referring to them as male or
biologically male during the May 11th
episode of Walsh's daily Wired podcast
the Matt Walsh oh he called trans girls
quote boys with XY chromosomes and
penises oh my god and claimed that quote
people are like mr. Potato Head dolls
now you just take the different parts
swap them out doesn't matter it makes no
difference I did say that he also
claimed he also claimed that the
athletes are not females quote not by
science not by common sense and not by
human decency
the following day walsh doubled down on
his remarks and called trans athletes
quote penis wielding XY z-- that's
terrible
terrible
and claimed quote they're not girls and
they're certainly not female Shapiro the
outlets founder also misgendered the
athletes during the May 11th edition of
the Ben Shapiro show referring to them
as biological males throughout the
segment on May 13th Noel's
fear-mongering about trans inclusive
sports on his daily wired podcast
claiming that quote if the left can
force you to believe that men are women
and women are men then there is no
objective reality Noel's also said that
accepting transgender people's gender
identity is how quote science is abused
and appropriated and monopolized and
diverted and transformed to invert
objective reality the daily wire
regularly spreads hateful anti-trans
content that earns significant
engagement online okay there it is well
yeah of course
every sane person listening to this
right now is thinking wait okay but
where is the offensive part I where's
the controversial part I don't I didn't
hear it I'm confused but that's it right
there that's that's that's all that's
all that stuff there where we say a
bunch of things that every single
rational human on planet earth agrees
with that's it that's that's the part
that they're upset about now a few
observations here first of all notice
again how the artificial and arbitrary
and invented distinction between sex and
gender has finally been abandoned by the
left it's important to notice what
they've done and it's it's long since
been abandoned but this is just more
evidence of that because the article
says we repeatedly misgendered the
athletes referring to them as male or
biologically male what wait a second I
thought male was sex and man was gender
that's what you guys told us for years
they're two different things that's what
we were told and now you're saying that
calling a male male is misgendering how
could it be miss gender if it refers to
sex and
sex and gender are two different things
according to you so you're saying that
sex and gender are two words for the
same thing now well of course they are
you know they're they're two words for
the same thing they always have been
well not always originally of course
gender was a linguistic term a
grammatical term words had gender not
humans so we didn't need to refer to
humans having gender because humans have
sex we don't need a second word for it
we've already got that covered but words
on the other hand don't have a sex
because they're not biological entities
and that's why we have gender to refer
to you know masculine or feminine words
but what the left did is they they they
said okay we're going to take this this
grammatical concept and we're gonna
apply it to people and and these are two
different things well apparently not now
they've gone back on that they're
they're not just saying that gender is
fluid they're saying that sex that
biological sex is fluid so this is the
ultimate bait-and-switch leftist they
tried to normalize this idea of gender
fluidity this idea that gender is a
separate thing and it can change or
switch back and forth and then right
when people started to buy into it which
nobody ever should have in the first
place they without announcing it switch
switch sexes back for gender so they
tried to get us used to the idea of you
know gender is this a different thing
now you could be biological male but
your gender could be woman and it's the
fluid thing and you know it could they
try to get a youth it's used to that and
in right when some people started
getting used to it they switched it
around and they said that odor no
actually that's yeah he's he's a he's
not a male at all he's a female they
went from trans women are women to trans
women are female which is a clever move
dishonest despicable false incoherent
you know all that stuff too but also
clever strategically number two second
point here and in fact before we get to
our
I can point wanted to tell you about our
friends at ab sleet you know if you're
having trouble falling asleep at night I
think it's time to try AB I have this is
a something I've constantly been plagued
by before I tried you know I've I say I
probably average about five four or five
hours of sleep a night which I'm told is
not necessarily healthy I'm told it
could actually shorten your life span
you should be getting a lot more sleep
than that but you know I have trouble
with it and that's why AB is great AB is
the first and only wearable drug-free
solution that targets the root cause of
sleeplessness which is which are those
racing thoughts ed is clinically
validated and four out of five users
report falling asleep faster and
improving overall sleep quality it's a
lot better in my opinion than taking
drugs didn't want to get you don't to
get dependent on that and also they can
make your groggy and that's not the best
solution ed sleep is designed to work
with your natural sleep wake rhythms to
allow you to get into that deep sleep
more quickly ed sleep understands that
uncertainty you may be experiencing at
this time and they want to help our
listeners can save twenty five dollars
off your order by using promo code mat
to save and continue to try AB risk-free
for 60 nights to confirm it's the
solution you've been looking for at Tri
EV comm / mat let us help you get the
sleep you need and remove the risk from
your purchase that's T TR y eb b.com /
math try EV comm / mat use promo code
mat to save order today with everything
going on you need to get the sleep you
need and deserve
okay second point about this you notice
how there's no argument presented here
right and there never is this is just a
motion I mean my kids would be better at
presenting a rational argument than this
so this this is what I'll say it's a
Alex and Media Matters and and all
leftist with respect to this issue and
and every issue really here's what I'll
say how about this get it out of your
system okay you can yell scream cry call
me a bigot sure yes I'm a bigot I'm a
hateful terrible evil mean awful I'm
Hitler
I am litter
I'm worse than Hitler okay yeah up just
let's grant you that for the sake of
argument let's just so we can move on I
will grant you that you don't need to
scream it anymore yes all that is true
we've established it get it out of your
system out of the way okay hopefully you
feel better hopefully we've we've we've
gotten past that part of the discussion
we've laid that framework
can we please now move on to the part of
the discussion where you actually try to
explain why I'm wrong no stop don't
don't start calling me a transfer
Don : don't go into the phobes in the
and the is and the isms we've already
done that we're past that now okay yes
I'm a phob I'm a NIST I'm an ism lay
them all on me I really don't care we've
already covered those bases though so
those bases are covered
lets us move past it you don't need to
publish another article saying Matt
Walsh is a transfer we know that
everybody knows that fine
I don't care okay what I'm asking you to
do Alex at media matters or anyone else
over there or any leftist anywhere what
I'm asking you to do follow along please
okay just just just bear with me I'm
asking you to present an argument which
explains why and how I'm wrong and
you're right okay and it should be
really easy to do because I'm Hitler you
know I'm I'm a bigot I'm Hitler I'm all
these things I mean to beat me and an
argument should be super easy so just do
it that's all and I'm gonna let you
present it however you want but but I
would suggest that if you disagree with
my take on the definition of the word
male okay
or female no she stopped I I know you
want to start screaming big it again I
know you do you have like Tourette's and
you can't help but you don't need to
because we've already done
if you disagree with my definition of
the word female or male then what you
need to do really is is give me the
right definition okay that's all give me
the right definition give me the right
definition all you got to do and I'll
tell you what I'll make this interesting
too it will put some skin in the game
all right this is a deal that I'll make
with Media Matters right now on this
show
if anyone over there can give me a
coherent objective and valid definition
of the word female I will apologize I
will admit I'm wrong I will admit I'm a
bigot I've already done that but I'll
apologize it amid I'm wrong and I will
come on to this show tomorrow with a
rainbow flag draped around me and I will
pledge allegiance to the LGBTQ squad
okay that's what I do I promise you I
will if you can simply provide a
coherent objective and valid definition
of the word female the reason i
stipulate coherent objective and valid
is that because that's what a definition
has to be right in order to be a
definition but also you see you can't do
something like well the definition is a
female is a person who identifies as
female you can't do that that's not
gonna work okay because that by that by
definition is neither coherent objective
nor valid because you're using the word
you're defining in the definition for
one and two it's a definition that tells
me absolutely nothing about the thing
you're defining okay so if you say X is
a person who identifies as X that tells
me nothing about X I know absolutely
nothing about X based on that and
definitions are supposed to tell me
something in fact they're supposed to
tell me the definition so I should come
away knowing what the thing is because
you've defined it so you're gonna have
to do better than that right now just to
make this even easier I'll tell you what
my definition is okay I'll go first well
trade definitions here's my definition
of female
and this in fact is the dictionary's
definition too so I feel pretty safe
Webster agrees with me on this and in
fact actually every single biology
textbook that's ever been written ever
agrees with me and every Anatomy
textbook that's ever been written ever
agrees with me okay so this is our
definition I'm just gonna put it out
there for you a female a female human
let's be even more specific because
that's what we're talking about here a
female human is a person who bears two X
chromosomes has a vagina and barring
infirmity or old age can bear offspring
and produce eggs that's my definition of
a female person and according to that
definition those trans track athletes
are not female they're just they're just
not okay that's all not saying anything
else about them I'm just saying they're
not female and but the other people
competing in in you know in the girls
sports or the girls track teams and the
girls that are filing a loss they are
female okay they are fit they fit into
the definition that I had presented and
the definition that every dictionary in
every biology textbook and every naina
be textbook anywhere everywhere it says
um so they fit it to that definition
these other these trans individuals do
not and so that's why they shouldn't be
in the same week so your turn give me
your definition and we'll take maybe
your here's the thing I see you when it
comes to this issue you guys you've
never made any kind of argument ever you
never present any arguments so all of
the arguments are being made by people
on my side
who knows maybe we're wrong I mean we
could I don't think we are I mean I'm
I'm pretty damn confident we're not
wrong but maybe you have some kind of
like brilliant argument that you can put
forward that we just don't know about
and it may it may just blow my mind and
make me rethink everything I think I
know about the world maybe you do
so just if you do put it out there but
if you don't put it out there that I
think I'm fair in assuming you have no
arguments whatsoever and all you have is
emotions and tears and whining and
crying which is why your position can be
disregarded because it's irrelevant all
right so let's move on to headlines here
number one Washington Post magazine ran
a lengthy story on Stacey Abrams over
the weekend and the title that of that
story is the power of Stacey Abrams and
this is not a joke here's the picture
that's attached to that article that is
Stacey Abrams wearing a cape they
actually put her in a cape so this the
and the image a it looks like if Batman
died and his secretary had to take over
the superhero duties that's what this
looks like and here's an actual quote
let me pull this up here's an actual
quote from the article it says
pandemonium and pandemonium ensues as
she walks to the far left of the stage
like a runway supermodel stops on a dime
poses tilts her head slightly and smiles
camera flashes explode she next pivots
and walks slowly to the center of the
stage freezes there and repeats the pose
again
the flashes explode Abrams is summoning
her inner actress and she is both
enjoying the moment and getting through
it to get to the conversation
she then pivots and walks to the far
right of the stage same okay that's
that's that's the article
supermodel Stacy Hibbert
now this is not the first time the media
has tried to manufacture a political
superstar they obviously they do it all
the time the most famous example be
Barack Obama and that was a pretty
successful example okay they made him
president for eight years a less
successful example be better or ork they
tried their hardest with him to make him
into a superstar they had to give that
up but the difference here is that Obama
and even o'rourke at least to some
extent had some semblance of political
talent and charisma and so there was
something there even with Obama a pretty
good orator o'rourke not as good but at
least he has the whole punk rock thing
that he did in his in 90s and and so
he's got that going on and he's got the
furry thing so that's kind of
interesting so there's there's there's a
little something there that you could
try to build into this political
sensation if you want to but Stacey
Abrams are you see there's there's just
nothing there she's she's an extremely
standard extremely unimpressive normal
average politician in fact failed
politician she's just your average
failed politician very little charisma
or Talent nothing special as a public
speaker this is like if the right tried
to you know make Jeb Bush into a rock
star it just it doesn't work and the
attempts are becoming increasingly
embarrassing but like I said also
hilarious okay so Mashable number two
has a video out showcasing some new
protective gear that they're hoping
people will wear to protect themselves
from the carnivai rose and well you let
me know what you think take a look at
this
[Music]
honestly I would rather be dead
I would rather I would choose death over
wearing that for even five minutes of my
life now tell me if this is kind of mean
but when I saw that video I I did have
the thought that it would be kind of
funny if somebody straps that helmet on
right and and they're feeling super safe
and they're feeling impervious to to any
and all threats that they might have
come across and they walk outside of
their home and just really confident
step into the street immediately get hit
by a bus that would be kind of funny I
don't know if that's mean for me to I
you know I'd be really terrible for the
family of course but also a little funny
or maybe I'm just a bad person I think
it could be that it's funny and I'm a
bad person that's very probable as well
number three Rebecca brand is I'm not
sure who she is exactly but she recorded
a video over the weekend complaining
about people not wearing masks and now
her name is no longer Rebecca brand
anymore it's it's Karen and not just
this is this is not just Karen this is
the Karen this is the ultimate this is
like the the boss Karen at the end of
the game the quintessential Karen if
anyone wants to know if anyone's
confused about the Karen meme and where
that comes from and what is it Karen
well here it is right here oh my god not
one person with a mask on everybody is
here and nobody yeah oh my god that's
what I'm saying oh my god look at all
those people there's like 20 hi I'm
Rebecca brown and I'm flipping out
because governor Newsom announced at
this Friday we are no longer gonna be on
total lockdown
we're opening back up I'm flipping out
because people haven't been wearing
masks and this is gonna be even more
loosey-goosey than ever before I think
it's all gonna go downhill from this
point on loosey-goosey it's it's Lucy
listen I'll listen up all you loose
goose is loose geese get your acts
together this is of course there at the
beach you know and that's why people
aren't wearing masks Karen because
they're at the beach and they're outside
in the Sun and the chance that they pass
coronavirus on to anybody or contracted
themselves is almost zero and so that's
why they're not in masks at the beach
and that's why you don't need to be
either and I don't even understand I
don't how could you how is it why would
you even go to the your gonna wear a
mask at the beach why go in the first
place the hope its first of all it's hot
I mean imagine how hot it must be under
that mask and you're getting sand in it
and you know part of the whole thing
being at the beach is you can breathe in
that fresh sea air with the with the you
know the scent of the salt water you get
none of that you just get your own fumes
back up your nostrils what's the point
of even going well I know what the point
is for Karen there the point is to you
know a virtue signal and to show off how
responsible she is while everybody else
was being loosey-goosey as she says
number four nascar started back up again
I think of a few days ago over the
weekend which is great news you know and
then you think about so NASCAR started
up theirs they're playing soccer again
in in some places in the world and this
just makes me really excited for when
sports get get going again I mean real
sports you know so we got NASCAR and
soccer just makes me think I can't wait
till the sports leagues actually start
up again
number five incredible report here in
The Daily wire it says
democrat-controlled New York has
reportedly admitted to knowingly
undercounting the number of deaths
suffered in nursing homes from the
corner virus after the facilities were
devastated by Democrat Governor Andrew
Cuomo's policy that forced them to take
patients who were infected with the
virus the Daily Caller news foundation
reports the department made a subtle
change to its de closure disclosure
disclosures I can't read - its
disclosures beginning around May 3rd
according to its web archives
the New York State Department of Health
told the Daily Caller news foundation
its disclosure now only reports
coronavirus deaths for long-term care
patients that died while physically
present at their facility in other words
New York's nursing home and adult care
facility coronavirus death tracker omits
any individuals who contracted
coronavirus while living at a long-term
care facility but died in a hospital so
that's the way now I've commented on
this before you look across the country
and you see that that nursing home
deaths make up 40 50 60 70 sometimes 80
percent or more of the total deaths in
that state and then you look at at New
York and it's kind of strange because
there it's officially it's like 20
percent or less even though they had the
most deaths total by far of any state
and we know that they had this crazy
policy of deliberately forcibly
introducing the infection in Turner
Singh homes yet it's only what 15 20 %
of the deaths are nurse and that makes
no sense and so I've been saying for
weeks there's there's something going on
here and I think that number is gonna go
up and here it is reportedly that
they're saying okay it doesn't count as
a nursing home death if they die in the
nursing home so if somebody gets sick
and is on their death bed and they're
brought to a hospital for care and they
die there well we're not gonna call the
calls that call that a nursing home
fatality when in reality of course it is
so this is and why are they doing that
well because they're gonna protect
Andrew Cuomo because they realize that
this is a massive massive scandal and
easily one of the deadliest political
scandals in American history okay let's
move to your daily cancelation and
before we do you know I generally am NOT
a big fan of joy or happiness as you've
probably noticed I like to keep my safe
distance from those things social
distance six feet at least from joy and
happiness but I do want to share
something joyous with you the double
tumbler is back but it's only available
for our most exclusive membership tier
all access
the all access membership tier is our
premier level of membership all access
members get to participate in all access
live our new brand our brand new
interactive programming feature where
one of us daily wire hosts hang out each
night around 8 8 8 o'clock Eastern Time
5 p.m. Pacific and it's just a nice
casual conversation a lot of fun all
access membership now also includes two
of the irreplaceable leftist tiers
tumblers which by the way is also now
machine washable so I thought they were
all along I've been putting mine in the
washing machine I guess I should have
been doing that but now they are the
tumblers are literally overflowing with
feet with tears at the thought of this
off but joyful tears okay finally all
access members also get the benefits of
other membership tiers including an ADD
free website experience access to our
live broadcasts online you get three
hours of the Ben Shapiro show all of
that go to daily wire comm so I
subscribe to join all access and get 50%
off with coupon code Walsh right now
that's daily wire comm slash subscribe
okay so for our daily cancellation we're
gonna be cancelling the NFL and this for
me is a very solemn occasion because I'm
a huge football fan my huge NFL fan I
love everything about the NFL except for
the NFL itself that is the the
organization the bureaucracy I hate that
part but everything else I like so now
I'm canceling the organization and the
bureaucratic part of it the reason is
this reading a report now from nfl.com
it says during his State of the League
address three months ago at a Super Bowl
in Miami Commissioner Roger Goodell
acknowledged a need to increase the
opportunities for minorities to become
head coaches and general managers he
says clearly we're not doing enough we
have to do more blah blah blah
and okay get ready for this here's the
idea they came up with an idea they
proposed to incentivize teams to hire
minority coaches and front office
personnel like GM's and so on so quote
the idea is to incentivize the hiring of
minorities as head coaches or primary
football executives by rewarding teams
with improved draft slots
and it goes into details it says if a
team hires a minority head coach that
team in the draft preceding the coach's
second season would move up six spots
where it's slotted to pick in the third
round a team would jump 10 spots under
the same scenario for hiring a person of
color as its primary football executive
if a team were to fill both positions
with diverse candidates diverse
candidates in the same year the club
could jump 16 spots 6 for the coach 10
for the GM and potentially move from the
top of the third round to the middle of
the second ok so that's the idea
basically that goes into more detail but
that's you get the general gist so it
would seem that affirmative action in
the NFL much like its players is on
steroids because this is remarkable this
is the kind of thing that I might have
made up as a joke and proposed it in a
in an article or something satirically
this is Babylon B stuff right here it
really is they want to actually bribe
teams with draft position if they hire a
minority coach and just so you know if
you don't follow football draft position
especially in the second and third round
is extremely valuable so we're not
talking about seventh-round Flyers here
we're talking about they want to rig the
second round of the NFL Draft by giving
picks to teams if they hire quote
diverse candidates and buy diverse
candidates of course they mean black
okay they don't actually they don't want
diverse candidates that's not the point
there is one particular race that
they're looking for they want they don't
want to put it like that because it
would sound insane and degrading and
just absolutely weird but that is the
point so what are the problems here well
for one thing it's completely contrary
to the spirit of athletic competition
giving teams competitive advantages on
the basis of you know this is to destroy
the whole point of sports sports are a
meritocracy that's that's that's what's
so great about them that's why people
like them that's why
they are usually a respite they are in
oasis from all the the craziness with
the social engineering in the culture
you can go to sports and you just see
the best may the best man win that
that's it
or may the best team win not may the
most racially woke team win once you
start introducing that into it it
destroys the whole point of the endeavor
in the first place and for another thing
this is demeaning and infantilizing to
the people that it's supposed to help
because what you're doing here is you're
creating suspicion reasonable suspicion
that any black coach or black GM who's
hired from here on out was only hired
because of the reward that the team
would get for hiring them which
inevitably that will be the case for
some of the black coaches of black teams
that are hired if this plan goes through
but then they're gonna be others that
would have been hired anyway just based
on their merits based on their
qualifications and their skill but they
also are going to be forever tainted by
the suspicions of racial favoritism so
it doesn't help them and then of course
on the other hand this guarantees that
some candidates white candidates will be
passed up despite being the most worthy
and most qualified based solely on their
race so it guarantees that based on
their race there are going to be some
candidates who are overlooked it
guarantees racial discrimination in
order to solve racial discrimination so
we're getting rid of potential
theoretical racial discrimination by
replacing it with guaranteed racial
discrimination great plan just just
wonderful plan and you know the last
thing if we're going down this route why
don't we incentivize teams to put you
know white cornerbacks on their rosters
there are zero white quarterbacks in the
NFL right now as far as I know certainly
there are none that start so there are
zero starting white corners in the end
of
not very many weight running backs a few
not very many white wide receivers a few
not very many white free safeties or
linebackers or well not very many white
players in general except at the
quarterback kicker and offensive line
positions those are the only places
where you typically are going to find
white people so why don't we give
incentives for that oh right because
this is not really about racial
diversity at all this is about racial
dogmatism left-wing racial dogmatism to
be specific and that's what the NFL is
considering it's you know it hasn't
passed but if it does it's just it I'm
pretty cynical and so it's hard to
surprise me but this this really does
and I think we have a couple emails here
but I think we'll save those for
tomorrow because it could be longer
conversations so we'll leave it there
thanks I'm ready for watching thanks for
listening have a great day
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there